all right so Daniel Radcliffe is done
with Harry Potter and now he's in a new
role where he's in a haunted ass house
and he's got no patron assist to help
him this time last Potter joke swear the
woman in black alright so when woman in
black Daniel Radcliffe is this young
lawyer and he's like I'm gonna do what
young lawyers do I'm gonna go to this
town and stay in this crickety ass house
this house you take one look at it
you're like that's a CD at that thing is
haunted the entire cast of Ghost Hunters
Ghostbusters and Ghost Adventures could
not put that place back in order it's
pretty bad and in this house he's
staying in is the woman in black alright
so for the first part of the woman in
black I was like mmm I mean it seemed
kind of slow the movies building up but
I was like come on let's get something
happening and then it relied heavily on
jump scares I mean crows flying in front
of the screen cat or whatever I was like
alright jump scare movie that's kind of
slow right now this movie's gonna have
to do something then lo and behold the
movie did something movie started
scaring the out of me the jump
scares were a little more relevant you
felt like ghosts were just everywhere it
did that thing with the soundtrack for
the soundtracks like boom right when
something comes out at you but it did it
in a way where it wasn't just when it
happened it's like something's on the
screen it's like the movie knew right
when you realize that that was there
then it did that and ever somewhat
reason was way more effective so it's
not really it jump-scare and the other
jump scares in the movie have an image
that just burns into your brain where
you're like epenow forgetting that not
for a couple days and this movie has
this segment this segment felt like 30
minutes long but I'm pretty sure it was
like 10 or 15 this is like the scariest
I had goosebumps for 15 minutes
really effective man this stuff work and
what sets this movie apart from a lot of
other scary movies is the camerawork
example there are creepy dolls
everywhere in this mansion it's like
1889 so they're gonna be creepiest dolls
whenever they came on-screen I was like
yeah that's like 100 bucks on Pawn Stars
but it does these close-up shots with
these dolls with a face it's really
clear and everything around it is just
blurry makes it feel really isolated
like these things are alive props to the
directing and camerawork on that and
even for Daniel Radcliffe sake I was
glad this movie was effective
dudes done with one franchise he's like
I don't want my career to die with that
movie like you know carrie fisher's
different star wars he was good in the
movie it's weird to see him have a kid
but he has a kid in the movie you're
like mm that's right he's not Harry
Potter it's not a Potter joke it's
different I'm just making a point you
may find the
was part of the movie slow but in the
end this movie had some really creepy
parts deuce bumps all over I was
thinking about this movie when I got
home my eyes were playing tricks on me
when I was walking out to my car that's
what I'm talking about that's what I
need when I come out of a movie like
this needs to stick with you in the end
this movie is a creepy-ass time no
alcohol required if you like scary
movies or horror movies this is your
movie check it out so if you seen the
woman in black what did you think of it
if you haven't seen yet what's that
movie that just gave you goosebumps man
that just stuck with you comment below
let me know this movie still sticking
with me I got these lights on these
lights weren't on be in that corner it
would be sad and as always if you like
what you seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more